I remember Deborah's mom in terms of
endearment was played by the legendary
Shirley MacLaine and in a career that's
six decades well she has seen it all she
has done it all and she was ready to
talk about it all when we sat down
together IV plastic surgery her open
marriage yeah and what it's like to be a
role model to the hottest young
actresses of today so many young
actresses look up to you I know you talk
about Jennifer Lawrence I'm impressed
with her what was the advice that you
gave her never leave Kentucky be
yourself that you arnis of her
unconventional with no filters do you
see some of yourself in Jennifer yes I
do
they're both Oscar winners and both live
by their own rules like did you know
that at 81 years old
Shirley still loves to flirt and is
totally into picking up men it's
fascinating to see what attracts me what
does it is age and another person
probably humor intelligence and they
can't be skinny or little they've got to
be big and potentially dominating but
gives me something to do
yeah for Shirley life's all about
calling your own shots she's outspoken
in her belief in reincarnation and says
having an open marriage is the key to
relationships excessed
in fact Shirley and her husband Steve
Parker made that work for nearly three
decades another piece of advice has to
do with fashion you say being chic just
takes too much time and effort I want to
be in my gym pants I love you for that
when I was actually 21 22 I would you
know put on something that had a tight
waist do the red carpet go to the ladies
room
undo the tight waist and get back in my
car so I wouldn't have to do anything
else in the tight waist gotta say I
loved sitting down with the Hollywood
icon at Christie's in Malibu she has a
new book above the line which is all
about her crazy experience shooting a
movie yet to be released and Shirley
gave me a Hollywood plastic surgery
secret something called facelift tape
explain how that works
they're on I don't know levers and you
do a bobby pin and you lift your chin so
it goes up and then you have a headache
by lunch
so curious we looked up facelift tape on
YouTube and this is what we found
intriguing and slightly freaky well I
think I'll just rely on Shirley and her
final tip for succeeding in life
breathe deeply be alone well the big
word be just be and then things will
start to actually be a limb self she was
just so incredible that Hawk - and as we
sat there she said I look into your eyes
and I can see into your soul it's what I
do with people and there's a cool
connection I also asked her Lee what her
favorite movie was that she starred in
huh she said terms of endearment five
Kleenex five Kleenex use my box there
you go good point